Speaker 1: Hey, we have a voicemail line,
and often the voicemails are just disgusting.
I have one of the nicest voicemails I've ever
received to play for you today. You can call the
voicemail line anytime to one nine two David P.
Call anytime you want. Here is just a beautiful
voicemail in a sea of insults and ad homonyms.
Speaker 6: Hi. I was just wanting to say that
I think that you're an
amazing person. Thank you. And
I'm really happy about how your show has
progressed over the years. I've watched it.
I hope you continue to do what
you're doing and stay healthy
and stay who you are. Thank you for watching.
Speaker 1: What a nice message. What a truly
just nice message. Those really are rare and I
appreciate it, but criticisms are welcome as well.
Two one nine two David P. is the number, call it
any time bonus show today. OK, we're going to dove
deep into Republican redistricting plans based
on the 2020 census. Number one, it's clear from
their early plans that they are going with the
gerrymandering, full speed ahead. And number two,
there are even proposals to slice up liberal
cities and to put a little bit of one liberal
city, in part as part of a rural district
and another part of a liberal city, and to
basically try to completely eliminate the reality
that liberal cities should be represented by
the liberal elected officials that those liberal
cities want to see representing them. So we're
going to talk about all of that on today's
bonus show. We are also going to talk about
a Connecticut doctor who was giving patients
blank COVID 19 exception for exemption forms
vaccine exemption forms. The doctor would sign
them and give them to patients. And then if the
patient needed a vaccine exemption for whatever
reason, they could use this doctor's signature.
She has surrendered her medical license
now the doctor, and that's a good thing,
and we're going to talk about that. How do
you get access to the bonus, Joe? You go to
join Pacman dot com and sign up. That's it. And
then lastly, Tuesday, October 19, we are doing a
an exclusive viewer town hall where I will
just open the phones and take questions from
everybody. 6:00 PM Eastern Tuesday, October
19th It will be streamed exclusively on our
second YouTube channel, Pacman Live. Find
it at youtube.com slash Pacman Live or
David Pakman dot com slash Pacman live, whatever's
easier to type. Either way, October 19th. Tuesday,
six East Three West members get priority, but we
will be opening opening up the Discord lines to
everybody. All right, we'll talk to you
on the bonus show and see you tomorrow.